you've got an amazing on-screen
chemistry with your [ __ ] partner played
by jake gyllenhaal on screen can you
tell me a little bit about what it was
like working with him how you got that
bond on screen and also you did a lot of
research with ride-alongs with cops
didn't you so tell me about that too
well at first it was like we didn't get
it we get along very well because I mean
he just is just a different guy I grew
up in you know like kind of I guess you
could say like the ghetto in Chicago and
he grew up in you know in Los Angeles
were both of his parents were in the
entertainment business and so it took us
a little bit but I think us putting in
that much work we're like aw man we got
to make this work and after the first
month we're like dude it's not working
let's let's try to see if we can we can
make it happen and then I also spent a
lot of time with Natalie Martinez who
plays my wife you know we would go on
many dates for two to three times a week
for five months and that was the easiest
i think you know relationship out of
anything but yeah I mean it's we wanted
to make it real we wanted to make it
look like we were brothers you know like
brother from another mother yeah and it
was it was tough but it's one of the
most rewarding movies I've done as well
and those ride alongs as well oh my yeah
there was there it was pretty nasty I'm
like there's not too many times where
you know we're actors you know but we
saw people shot in the face and you know
he saw a person died and there was this
guy that shot in the face and the arms
and abdomen and then women that were
battered and that didn't want to press
charges on their on their husbands and
and then little kids that were hurt like
it just it was brutal but it was
definitely like it opened your eyes to
what reality is and you know how how
many little people actually really get
to live above poverty how do you go home
and feel after you've seen something
like that well you needed some
decompression which is pretty much the
same thing that these cops feel and so
it was interesting but we it's like life
imitating art you know domain in a way
thanks so much is speaking to smoke as a
pleasure thank you
you